the four Empress of the sea are the most
powerful characters in all of One Piece
but on top of being the absolute
strongest beings in the world they also
play a very important political role in
balancing out the powers of the world so
I want to break down the complex Emperor
system by discussing its history its
purpose who each Emperor is and was and
how they all became so mind blowingly
powerful in the first place starting
with the fact that just one of these
ridiculously strong characters is enough
to make the world government cry like a
little baby in fact when just one of the
Emperors attacked Marine Fort
headquarters they had to call in every
single one of their strongest fighters
to even have a chance to survive and so
you might be asking yourself well Manu
if these Empress are so powerful then
why haven't they already taken out the
world governments which is an excellent
question that I promise we will be
answering if you make it to the end of
this video but first let's start with
the basics here because in the one piece
world the pirate captains with the most
influence and power are typically the
ones called Emperors of the sea and so
at the start of the story itself there
were originally four Emperors who we
will be talking about in more detail in
just a second however honestly the
emperor system itself isn't really an
official organization where the Pirates
get together and kind of figure out who
is the strongest fighter there instead
it is more based on who the world
government and its people view as the
strongest and most important Pirates
which of course isn't a perfect system
and can lead to some very hilarious
mistakes now we do have to keep in mind
though that even though most of the
Emperors are actually ridiculously
powerful on their own it usually isn't
enough to just be ridiculously powerful
as a fighter because what really puts a
character at Emperor tier level is the
fact that they have a ton of super
strong allies and usually rule over
important territories in the most
dangerous part of the world which is the
new world in the grand line and yeah
we'll talk about the structure of each
of the emperor's Crews later on as well
but before that it's really super
important to understand the emperor's
real purpose in the story because what
you might not know is that although most
of the emperor claim to be going after
the one piece treasure their actual main
purpose in the story at least is
basically to be an obstacle to stop any
other of the younger Pirates trying to
find the one piece and there able to do
this because in order to find the
legendary final Island left tail which
has the one piece you do need the four
of these unbreakable red stones which
tell you the way to get to that islands
and so at the start of the story two of
these red stones were held by the
emperor kaido and big mom which means
that they are somewhat close to finding
the one piece although they don't seem
to have made any progress for like
decades and that might actually be
because they rarely come into conflict
with each other because if two Emperors
were were to actually go all out and
fight it would leave both of them
extremely weak and vulnerable to attack
from let's say a third emperor or even
the Marines yeah if you are a young
pirate trying to get the one piece good
luck trying to take out any of these
monstrous Fighters but this is exactly
why there is basically a stalemate in
the new world for most of the story
where no one is truly making progress
towards the one piece itself I mean for
one the Marines can take out any of the
Emperors without seriously weakening
their position young Pirates join or get
taken out by the empress and the yonos
themselves don't really want to fight
each other as well which if you put it
like that does sound kind of boring but
you might be surprised to learn that
that is exactly how the world government
actually wants things to be and that's
because this way no one makes it any
closer to actually finding the one piece
or learns anything about the world
government's darkest Secrets oh and I
actually just lied when I said that no
one is making progress towards the one
piece because if you've been following
the story at all then you will know that
the main character Luffy is of course
getting very close to finding this
legendary treasure and at this point at
the end of the wano arc Luffy is
officially considered an emperor of the
sea as well for real this time which
actually gave us a really interesting
Glimpse at how a character actually
becomes an emperor because taking down
the emperor kaido made it so the entire
world simply had no other choice but
recognize him as one of the strongest
and most influential Pirates around
however despite what you might think
right now actually just defeating an
emperor doesn't automatically mean that
you become the next one because for
example when Blackbeard dealt the final
blow to the emperor Whitebeard he wasn't
automatically given Emperor status
instead blackbeat actually had to do the
work and wipe out the rest of white
beit's crew during the time skip in
order to finally be recognized as an
emperor by the rest of the world so
again it's a combination of super
impressive defeats against the other
Emperors as well as Global
acknowledgment of a pirate being truly
influential but this system isn't
perfect because as we saw when Luffy
escaped from Hulk Island he was called
an emperor even though the other
Emperors could tell that he wasn't quite
strong enough yet and what happened at
the end of wano was maybe even more
hilarious because the newspaper and
world government started calling buggy
the clown a new Emperor as well because
of the simple fact that they think he is
the leader of a group of marine hunting
Pirates however in reality he's just the
figurehead and the real power lies with
these two right here so like I said not
a perfect system at all but what may
completely shock you is that the empress
system in itself has probably not even
existed for very long at all I mean to
be fair we don't know for sure but so
far it seems like when people talk about
the strongest pirates from an era it was
usually one or two Pirates Who were
super strong and were capable of taking
over the world specifically here I'm
talking about 40 years ago with the
pirate roxc who was said to be so strong
he could almost conquer the entire world
and after him it was the pirate Goldie
Rogers era which makes me think that the
emperor only really became a real thing
once Roger started the great pirate era
after the execution 23 years ago though
to be fair we don't really know so it's
possible that before becoming pirate
king Roger was also considered an
emperor alongside people like Whitebeard
kaido and big mom who were all already
active at the time and before we talk
more specifically about each of these
legendary Pirates it is super important
to discuss the actual structure of the
emperor's Cruise because as I said these
crews are truly massive compared to
regular pirate crws in one piece and
most Emperors have multiple Islands
under their control as well and so in
general each Emperor will have a group
of insanely powerful top commanders
right below them though this varies kind
of depending on each Emperor for example
kaido has three Allstar commanders while
Shanks has a quite large group of nine
senior officers and these Commander
level crew mates are usually incredibly
powerful on their own with each one
easily capable of wiping out entire
pirate Crews on their own and now
besides their main crew each Emperor
typically also has Allied themselves
with captains that will come to fight at
their command this was of course
perfectly shown during the Marine Ford
War when Whitebeard 43 Allied captains
all came to fight for him but even one
of the newer Emperors like Blackbeard
still has Allied Pirates working under
him like we saw with this guy right here
and then of course Luffy himself also
has his Straw Hat Grand Fleet who are
pirate captains who did pledge to come
to fight for him when he needs help and
on top of all the strong subordinates
the Emperors usually control one or more
Islands who are under their protection
as well for example big mom has a whole
territory of of 35 Islands which made up
her dream Paradise called toddland then
of course we have kaido who of course
has taken over wano country but we also
have seen that he has control of some
other random Islands as well and since
these territories are under the
protection of an empera anyone who
attacks them risks becoming a target of
that yonos crew for example we saw this
during the fisherman island arc which at
the time was under big mom's control and
Luffy's action there made big mom
instantly label him an enemy on the
other hand we have characters like this
guy here who ransacked one of shank's
territories and we later on saw Shanks
and his crew talking about getting
revenge on that crew which at this point
you should probably know that things are
probably going to end very badly for
this rack Tech bunch of Luffy supporters
but you can actually avoid that same
tragic fate and get on all of the
emperor's good sides by just clicking
the nice red subscribe button below this
video to get more one piece content just
like this and now we cannot talk anymore
about the Emperors without discussing
the single biggest Clash of Emperor
level characters in the entire story and
of course I'm talking about the giant
conflict on the mysterious island of God
Valley which happened over 40 years ago
and honestly if I had to guess this is
very likely the birthplace of the modern
Emperor system itself because without
getting into too many details here we
had the legendary Roxy zbec Who was the
strongest pirate of his era clashing
with the future pirate king Goldie Roger
and while we don't know if Roger and Rox
were ever officially called emperor of
the sea I simply had to bring this up
because once Rox was defeated his crew
ended up being separated to form their
own pirate Crews and wow this completely
changed the entire world because this
group had three future Emperors
including big mom kaido and Whitebeard
like seriously what an insane pirate
crew and so this is of course the origin
of the future world's strongest man
because after this Whitebeard later went
on to become Roger's greatest rival but
honestly Whitebeard was the best kind of
pirate like sure he stole some treasure
and smacked down smaller pirate Crews
like Aces Spade Pirates but his true
dream was just to have a family of his
own which of course is exactly what
ended up happening because his entire
massive crew were basically like his
sons and daughters which does mean that
he would have done any anything for any
of them including enter an allout war
with the Marines just like we saw during
the war at Marine forts which to this
day is still the most insane War Arc I
have ever seen and it was so epic in
large part because Whitebeard is so
stupidly powerful with his Tremor devil
fruit which can literally destroy entire
Islands but Whitebeard of course wasn't
alone here because he also had his
supersized crew led by the 16 Division
commanders Plus 43 Allied pirate captain
so clearly he was a beloved Captain who
was well respected by his crew allies
and even older Marines like Luffy's
grandfather gar and even the former
Fleet Admiral soku and I think at this
point it's also incredibly important to
understand that each of the Emperors so
far also have helped us understand
Luffy's growing strength on his way to
become pirate king as well for example
when Luffy meets Whitebeard he was
nowhere near strong enough to take out
the elderly Emperor but he was able to
earn whitebeard's respect which play
play a huge role later on when the
emperor's crew helped out Luffy which
makes it just completely mindblowing
that we can have well-respected Emperors
like Whitebeard but then we have
straight up evil Emperors like kaido and
as we've seen all throughout the wano
arc this man is power hungry and battle
crazy in fact for the longest time we're
being told that his dream is to die a
spectacular death just like his former
Captain rocks or even whitebeards but
this man takes this wish way too far
because he would literally destroy the
entire a world just to find a strong
fighter to satisfy his insane wish and
the worst part is is that he probably
could actually do it because he is just
that stupidly strong I mean even in his
base form he was powerful enough to join
rox's crew as a teenager and then on top
of that he got his legendary devil fruit
which gave him the powers of a literal
Dragon but if that's not enough he also
has some of the strongest hockey that we
have seen in the entire story like
seriously some times I still wonder how
Luffy was able to beat this guy in the
first place and in fact it was by
beating kaido that Luffy truly became
one of the Emperors in the first place
which we'll talk about more in just a
moment but of course kaido doesn't fight
alone as well because his crew is made
up of thousands of random Pirates and
exclusively animal zone devil fruit
users which includes some awesome
dinosaur fruits and also the super weird
SM fruit users which if you're lucky
give you some random animal part on your
body body however kaido's crew is not
the loving family that whitebeards was
because kaido actively encourages his
strongest subordinates to fight each
other in order to take one of the top
three Allstar Commander ranks of the
crew and what's even crazier though is
that kaido almost got his wish of
destroying the world when he teamed up
with big mom during the wano arc now
before this Alliance these two actually
hated each other for years but there's
no denying that big mom whose real name
is Charlotte linlin is a monstrous
fighter just like kaido if not more so
she also was part of the infamous Rock
crew from a young age but what's even
more impressive I think is that she took
out an entire Village of Giants at just
5 years old I mean come on that that's
just ridiculous and ever since then
she's had the Godlike powers of the Soul
devil fruit as well which let her take
the lifespan of people around her and
turn objects into living things plus as
we we saw during the whole cake Island
ARX she also has all three forms of
hockey which meant that when Luffy snuck
in to steal her Road poneglyph and get
his cookb he could not seriously fight
with her because he was just not strong
enough yet which did mean that Luffy
instead had to fight her strongest son
katakuri in order for the rest of the
straw hats to escape the island and
that's honestly one of the most
interesting things about big mom's crew
because it is literally made up of
exclusively her sons and daughters to be
precise 85 children and 43 husbands like
shees big mom indeed I guess she's
basically having kids every year but
does that mean that she's constantly
pregnant actually I don't really want to
know the answer to that however I think
it kind of makes sense because ever
since big mom was abandoned as a child
her true goal was to create a paradise
where all of the races of the world
could live together peacefully which I
mean she kind of did with totland except
that she was stealing everyone's souls
and anyone who pissed her off would be
killed and also she went on these random
rages so yeah not exactly Paradise but
more like a twisted version of the Free
World that Luffy wants to bring as well
however so far all three of the emperess
we've discussed have been either killed
or defeated I guess which means that
they have all lost their status as
empress which as a result now brings us
to the first of the current Emperors who
we're going to discuss who has actually
made his own pirate Paradise by becoming
the ruler of pirate islands and this is
of course Blackbeard who became an
emperor during the time Skip by
defeating the remainder of whitebeard's
crew and out of any pirate in the entire
story he has caused the single most
chaos in the entire world by killing
Whitebeard breaking some of the most
dangerous Pirates out of the prison to
form his ridiculously strong pirate crew
and stealing ridiculously powerful devil
fruits along the way to give to himself
and the rest of his crew in fact he is
the only person that we know of so far
to have eaten two devil fruits including
his Darkness fruit and whitebeard's old
Tremor fruit like seriously this guy is
insane and on top of all of this his
dream is to become king of the world
which means that he is Luffy's main
rival probably to become pirate king and
those two will undoubtedly be clashing
at some point in the story soon and
speaking of Luffy his path to becoming a
yongo was honestly maybe the most
difficult out of anyone I mean he had to
defeat kaido plus go through big mom
during the wano arc and he did all of
this with the help of his friends which
is the true essence of Luffy's dream I
guess yes we do all know that he really
wants to become pirate king but that is
only because he wants freedom for
himself and the people he cares for and
so he has achieved all of this with the
help of his Godlike devil fruit and by
learning all three types of advanced
hockey so truly he is worthy now of
being called an emperor plus of course
he has his crew which have become
incredibly strong in their own rights
and of course the straw head Grand Fleet
who will come fight for him whenever he
needs
them and now why you might think that
this next Emperor here is a joke I am
here to tell you that Emperor buggy
should be taken very seriously as a
threat to become pirate king that's
because he recently became an Emperor as
the leader of the Cross Guild Group
which hunts down Marines for bounties
but even though he doesn't seem to be
individually all that strong he does
seem to have an incredible amount of
influence in the pirate world that we
should take quite seriously that's
because for whatever reason he's always
able to inspire Pirates to do what he
wants which includes tricking much
stronger Pirates to fight for him as
well and at this point he has the
world's strongest Swordsmen and another
one of the former Warlords of the sea on
his side as well so the emperor team
buggy at least is no laughing matter at
all honestly though I've really no clue
yet if he will be Luffy's Ally or Enemy
by the end of the story but I wouldn't
be surprised at all if he would actually
end up being considered the King of
pirates at the end of the story as well
which of course now leaves us with red
hair Shanks who in my opinion is the
single strongest current Emperor and
despite being Luffy's hero from the
start of the story he could actually end
up being a serious rival to becoming
pirate king now we do actually know for
a fact that shang's only became an
emperor 6 years ago but it is only now
that Luffy has defeated kaido that he's
truly starting to pursue the one piece
treasure seriously himself which who
knows might have been his dream or goal
all along and if this is the case then
he's going to be a major threat because
we've actually been told by none other
than the Marines that Shanks has the
most well-balanced core crew out of any
of the yonko with high average bounties
and absolutely no apparent weak spots so
uh yeah good luck I guess uh taking out
the red hair Pirates but what's even
crazier is that it is very likely that
shank's crew will fight in some way or
form against the straw hats since they
do have this very similar road setup on
the crew such as a first mate a sniper
Navigator musician and so on and so
forth which means that Shanks and his
crew are just one of the possible
endgame opponents for Luffy as an
emperor but perhaps the more likely
option is not a pirate at all but
instead
the entire marine and World Government
forces because there is no way that the
PowerHouse Fighters like the Marine
Admirals will just let Luffy find the
one piece and change the world without
at least putting up a serious fight and
if you've ever been confused by the
entire world government Marine system
and want to know exactly how many Marine
ranks there are and how everything works
and fits together then you can watch my
breakdown of the entire Marine system
right here thanks for watching and I
will see you in the next
one